We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P.. Here is a very
interesting question about guns, which relates
to a conversation I've been having lately with
many friends of mine. Take a listen to this.
Hello, David. This is Antoine from Illinois.
And I was curious to know as whether
or not your stance on guns have changed
as a result of the impending violence
being hurt by the Trump administration.
Thank you. I hope you have, number one, the.
My position on the laws around guns has not
changed because of these lunatic armed Trump
ists. I still have the exact. Same position I
always have about background checks, high capacity
magazines, regulation. None of that has changed.
Where I have been having some conversations
with fellow progressive friends of mine
is do we really want them to be the ones with all
the guns? And as we now, we're on not even the eve
on the day of potential armed violence in the
streets. I have many friends, including, you know,
super progressive people in very blue states
who have the same views as I do on gun control,
on gun safety regulations, who have acquired
firearms. Now, I've got a question the other day
via super chat during a livestream about whether
I have firearms. And I said, I don't I don't
talk about there's no there's no advantage to me
talking about that. And so that's not something
I talk about. But there is no question that when
we think about how far are they willing to go if
Trump claims that it was rigged and that he really
won, even though Joe Biden is maybe going to win.
I don't love the idea of the right being the ones
with all the guns now at the same time. If I carry
that forward to its logical conclusion, what am I
saying? I'm saying well. In a shoot out situation
with armed Trump ists, I also want to have guns
to participate in the shoot out. I mean, it's a
crazy, dystopian, dark path you start going down.
But this is not something that has eluded many of
my ultra progressive friends and maybe a topic
for after the election. On today's bonus show,
more on today's election. What is producer
Patts electoral map look like compared to mine?
Number two, Election Day is becoming, in a
sense, a judgment day for social media. We
will talk about how and why. And lastly, it's
not just the White House. It's not just the
Senate and the House of Representatives tonight.
There are also local elections, but importantly
local ballot initiatives. We will talk about that
and so much more. This is it. This is it. It's
Election Day. Thanks to everybody who has been
following. Increasingly, our podcast audience has
doubled over the last four months. The YouTube
channel has exploded. Twitch Facebook. Facebook
is now bigger than YouTube was nine months
ago, if you can believe that, it's crazy.
Thanks to everybody. Let's hope that today is the
big reset and that tomorrow we start with the ship
marginally pointed in a better direction.
Bonus show. Get the bonus show by becoming
a member. It join Pacman. Com. See
you at 7:00 p.m. Eastern tonight.